una de las masacres más mortíferas en lo
que va de año en México las autoridades
federales anunciaron este jueves que la
matanza en el Estado de Guerrero de la
víspera atribuida Al enfrentamiento
entre integrantes de dos grupos del
crimen organizado Ya deja varias decenas
de Muertos entre ellos el regidor
municipal de San Miguel totolapan el
pueblo epicentro del ataque la
gobernadora del Estado condenolo
ocurrido Con promesas de cero impunidad
Lamento profundamente el sensible
fallecimiento del alcalde de San Miguel
totolapan Conrado Mendoza almeda condenó
los hechos y reitero que en la
gobernación de Guerrero no habrá
impunidad ante la artera agresión contra
el presidente municipal y funcionarios
del ayuntamiento la masacre
presuntamente llevada a cabo por las
disputas entre la familia michoacana y
Los Tequileros dos facciones criminales
que operan en el estado conmocionó al
país y también provocó el rechazo del
presidente mexicano en caso de
totolapan
son organizaciones
que vienen de tiempo atrás
no surgieron En este gobierno
y Estamos buscando atender las causas
desde el partido Revolución democrática
formación a la que pertenecía el alcalde
asesinado en la balacera pidieron
responsabilidades la dirección nacional
ejecutiva del PRD se suma al llamado del
periodismo guerrerense en Solidaridad
con las familias de totolapan Guerrero y
exige la renuncia del gabinete de
seguridad así como la investigación y
Castigo a los responsables del multi
homicidio durante el mandato de López
Obrador se han reportado 60 decesos de
representantes públicos según la agencia
etelec una tendencia violenta que se
mantiene al alza a todas las escalas en
el país